with elon's tesla revolutionizing the
entire car industry his boring company
making tunneling more possible than ever
and spacex single-handedly creating the
world of privately owned space
exploration there seems to be no limit
to his achievements however recently
there have been rumors that the
legendary tech god has his eyes set on
another industry that he seeks to change
and if he does it will affect every
single one of our lives that's right
rumors have not only been circulating
around but have started coming from
major sources that tesla is out to
create a phone unlike any other one by
the name of the pyphone that will work
on mars have 5g level internet in the
sahara and will be able to change its
color but does tesla really have a shot
at making this phone and how does it
compare to the world's current leader in
technology the apple iphone which you
might be using the answers to those and
more are in this video so buckle up if
you want to learn more and with that
said let's take a look at both of the
competitors with their history and
background iphone ever since its release
all the way back in 2007 at the hands of
steve jobs who some might say was an
elon musk of his era in his own right
the iphone has gone on to become the
most revolutionary piece of technology
to have ever been introduced everything
from the use of touch screens the
improvement of camera technology modern
internet services and general ui and
design choices that are seen in modern
phones is a direct result of the iphone
and even after more than a decade of
release they seem to be going just as
strong with nearly 200 million units
sold in just the previous year all the
while apple the manufacturer has gone on
to become the single most valuable
company in the world with a total worth
that is greater than most countries in
the world and so when we say the pyphone
has some big competition we mean it but
that doesn't mean that elon doesn't have
his own tricks up his sleeve pyphone
on the surface it may look like the
python is going to have a tough time
because of its young and startup-like
nature however the entire background
where it comes from is nothing short of
impressive we've already mentioned how
elon has revolutionized entire
industries and continues to do so and a
man who can change the entire car
industry one that's lasted nearly a
century over seven times the time
smartphones have lasted will probably be
able to make more than a ripple when he
decides to go mobile and another thing
that we get besides elon's expertise is
the sheer amount of resources he can
pool into this phone because well lest
we forget the man has been the world's
richest man more than a few times so
combining elon's expertise the technical
knowledge from all the different fields
his companies work in and the resources
he's gained from that we have a perfect
background for tesla to be able to make
the next generation of mobile telephone
technology and so now with the
background covered let's move on to the
exact specs and features that
differentiate both of the companies and
their offerings to start with let's talk
about the most striking feature of any
phone the design
to start let's go over the iphone now i
don't think i need to tell any of you
what an iphone looks like they used to
be rounded rectangles with rectangular
screens and a round home button and now
they look like rounded rectangles with a
nearly full screen and a long notch
however anyone who's used an iphone can
tell you that the most distinguishing
feature for them is their attention to
detail and quality as such the iphone 13
has aluminum sides a frosted glass back
and diamond cut details all of which
make for an awesome hand feel and
durability but let's just say the pie
phone has not only the standard stuff
but is rumored to have a back that is
covered with tiny photochromic scales
which will make it change color due to
the light it's in
the display not only is the design way
ahead of apple but the pi phone is also
rumored to have a full screen display
that has a camera hidden beneath the
screen and is capable of taking selfies
through the display and to round off the
physical features let's talk about the
camera
in this department long dominated by
apple itself the pi phone is rumored to
have four camera lenses compared to the
iphone 13's three allowing it probably a
greater zoom capability and while we
don't think it'll beat apple in photo
quality tesla might be able to integrate
their ai technology that they use for
self-driving for stuff like object
recognition and other features and that
brings us to another phone feature ai
and software
apple is known for using stuff like siri
as assistants and their latest phones
have some of the most impressive ar
technology out there which is stuff that
blends the real world with a digital one
allowing you to make virtual maps of
rooms and play interactive games but
that has nothing on the pi phone's
neural link for those familiar with
elon's empire the name may sound oddly
familiar and that's because it's the
name of elon's company that is
researching ways to implant chips in
people's brains allowing them to
communicate with tech telepathically
neural links working well in um in
monkeys we were also doing
just a lot of testing
and just confirming that it's it's very
safe and reliable and that
the neural link device can be removed
safely what this means is that if not at
release in the future the pi phone may
be controllable through brain signals
alone with no physical touch needed and
that brings us to the final major part
of a phone connectivity
all of apple's latest phones including
the iphone 13 are capable of running on
the latest 5g cellular network and
although that might sound really small
right now as the network grows it'll
allow phones to have internet speeds
that parallel those of wired connections
on the go and with a 5g penetration rate
swiftly climbing to 37 in 2021 that
future might be near however not only
will the pi phone have 5g enabled it may
actually be the world's most
well-connected phone due to a little
something called starlink starlink like
the aforementioned neural link is one of
elon's ventures only this time its
impact is a lot more tangible to you and
me basically this network will consist
of thousands of satellites in orbit
around the earth all of which will join
together to create this literal cloud of
internet to which special starlink
radars will be able to connect directly
from literally anywhere on the planet
from the sahara to the amazon rainforest
to get access to fiber quality internet
this means that in the near future with
the use of a device the size of a table
anyone can have access to the internet
anywhere and you guessed it the pi phone
is going to be natively integrated into
this network meaning that if the rumors
are true pyphone users may not even need
the middle router and will be able to
have direct internet 24 7 literally
anywhere in the world making it the
single most well-connected phone out
there and so now with all the technical
aspects and rumored features of the
phone talked about let's move on to the
last major factor that will decide which
phone comes out victorious
where both companies are
at the time of the recording of this
video apple is the world's most valuable
company with a market cap of nearly
three trillion dollars not only that but
we shouldn't forget the fact that in the
phone world there is a lot more
competition than just the iphone
according to trend force a market
intelligence firm states that at this
moment the world's biggest phone makers
in order are samsung apple xiaomi oppo
vivo and huawei and collectively just
these six make up about eighty percent
of the entire global phone market and so
to summarize to make the pi phone work
tesla will have to do an amazing job and
it may take some effort and luckily for
them they are no slouch themselves you
see while many used to consider them the
underdog of the automaker world right
now they enjoy being the first automaker
to hit one trillion dollars in market
capitalization and as a result being the
most valuable car makers in the world
and with many analysts saying that the
company is just beginning with ventures
like robo taxis driven by ai changing
how people move it might not be too long
before they too will be vying for the
spot of biggest company in the world
making the companies fight more directly
than ever and speaking of direct
competition did you know that apple
might be making their own electric car
that's right just this week reporters
from bloomberg revealed that the
cupertino tech giant is moving fast
toward completing their ev venture which
is impressive in its own right using
apple's software mastery to push toward
a car that has a fully self-driving
system in the first version unlike tesla
and other electric cars which are only
slowly increasing the self-driving
functionality of already existing cars
and so what we realize from this is that
both companies are in the unique
position of where either could have a
chance at beating the other and it'll
all depend on who embraces the future
first and how well they do that and that
finally brings us to the conclusion
with the pyphone tesla seeks to create a
world in which phones are far more
connected durable and have a larger
range than ever before and while the
iphone is undoubtedly the single most
important product to have been launched
in the past two decades with features
like tesla's revolutionary neurolink
integration native access to starlink
and their unique design approach if they
do it right they might just beat apple
and with devdiscourse.com reporting in
september that 2021 did not pass by elon
musk every day in search engines people
ask the same question is tesla releasing
a phone
yes we will see elon musk's smartphone
soon we can rest assured that the
smartphone world is about to get a lot
more exciting and it's going to get
there fast and well on that note we must
end today's video i hope you enjoyed
watching it and if you did be sure to
leave a like and subscribe for more also
click on this video to learn more about
apple's self-driving car with that take
care and i'll see you guys next time